le cancer assez remplie d'hommes braves
je ne veux pas être un homme brave je
veux être un grand tabou
pensons n'avoir rien la tromperie
[Musique]
et ce rêve
vous êtes au pays d'oz je suis théodore
à la gentille sorcière est votre balai
vous ne savez même pas ce qu'est une
sorcière c'est la cité d'émeraude la
prophétie vadon se réaliser voici ma
soeur et ban aura pour vous servir
le trésor royal du pays d'auros
il vous appartient à condition que vous
parveniez à vaincre la méchante sorcière
méchante à quel point
ils ont été détruites les enfants sont
devenus orphelins
le grand magicien du kansas les
votre venue vous seul pouvez rétablir la
paix moi
c'est quand baudis que nous allons
mourir j'ai bien entendu la force de
votre magie plutôt qu'hors de sauver
[Musique]
dis toi que vous êtes capable de vous
battre non mais nous chantons messieurs
petit on craque
l'ennui c'est que je ne suis peut-être
pas pas vraie passion des personnes
abusées
vous êtes bien plus compétents que vous
ne le pensez
[Musique]
n'êtes vous pas le grand homme que nous
attendions
[Musique]
si c'est fort possible
[Applaudissements]